the kingdom of Yugoslavia came into
existence just after World War I and its
name means the kingdom of the South
slaves yet as many of you will know its
borders didn't incorporate all of the
Southern slaves since Bulgaria wasn't a
part of it but given how powerful the
movement of panslavism was at the time
why didn't Bulgaria ever join Yugoslavia
so Yugoslavia came into existence just
after World War I as Austria Hungary was
falling apart these Slavic regions Broke
Free and declared the creation of the
state of slovin croats and serbs which
very quickly asked for political union
with Serbia the reason for this was that
yugoslavism the movement for the
unification of Southern Slavic people
had been a powerful rallying Force
against the H Habsburg Empire in
Bulgaria yugoslavism wasn't a very
powerful motivator though the kingdom
saw itself as the successor to the
medieval Bulgarian Empire and it had
already existed as an independent
country for 40 years and as such its
people didn't need yugoslavism to
motivate them since they had good
oldfashioned nationalism and irredentism
speaking of which Bulgaria and Serbia
had been to war twice over the previous
decade and as such unsurprisingly their
peoples hated each other Bulgarian
leadership claimed these lands and the
people there as their own the two
countries continued their Mutual
distrust until World War II when
Bulgaria helped the axis in carving up
Yugoslavia before also helping them to
lose the war it was occupied by Soviet
troops and both it and Yugoslavia became
communist Nations soon afterwards this
presented an opportunity for unification
because communist ideology pushed
internationalism over nationalism and
ethnic Division and in 1947 both signed
the bled agreement which brought the
countries closer together and were seen
by both as the first step towards
unification there was one slight hiccup
though both sides had very different
ideas about what the unification would
look like the bulgarians saw greater
Yugoslavia as a confederation of two
equal countries and that Bulgaria would
gain these lands from Yugoslavia in
return for joining the union they would
maintain separate internal policies but
would act with unity on foreign and
defense issues Tito would never accept
this because a union of equals would see
Bulgaria dominate Yugoslavia whereas
Tito's belief was that the proposed
Union would see Bulgaria broken up into
numerous socialist republics and
autonomous regions with this bit
becoming a part of Macedonia which
importantly would not be considered
Bulgarian anymore Bulgaria would ceased
to exist and the Yugoslavian leadership
would oversee the running of it this was
never actually going to fly with
Bulgaria though and so the deal was Dead
on Arrival doubly so when you consider
that Stalin didn't like the plan and
demanded that it go no further and when
Stalin and Tito fell out the bulgarians
were hopeful that with the backing of
the entire communist World they would
soon be able to take Macedonia for
themselves and so any Prospect of
Bulgaria joining Yugoslavia was for good
I hope you enjoyed this episode with a
special thanks to my patrons James Bizet
Kelly Money Maker Sky Chappelle kitka
Andy mgee Anthony Becket Alex Schwin rod
D Martin Udan Wang AF Firefly Spencer
lighfoot Marcus arner Y and hockey
Captain side dog Marvin CAU kimun Yun
the mcer Gustav Swan Maggie Paskowski
calling Dr Howard Dr Fine Dr Howard
spinning three plates copper tone shenin
words about books podcast Ked Alder Wood
Winston kwood Jim Stromberg Charles I
and Miss is it